Some classes will make use of
the tests and quizzes function.
When a test is open,
you'll see them here.
Most tests have a time limit.
And you'll see the limit here.
You must complete the test by the time
limit or else it will auto submit.
Make sure to save your answers.
So, let's go through this
final exam real quick.
You'll receive some
instructions on this page, and
be reminded of the time limit here.
So now you will click
Begin Assessment to get started.
Now we will go through
the questions one by one.
Some of them might be fill in the blank,
like this one.
Some of them might be essay questions,
Some might be multiple choice,
like this one.
Now when you're done with the exam
click submit for grading.
Click this one more time to
confirm that you are done.
You will then receive
a confirmation screen.
Once the exam has been graded
you will see feedback here.
Here you will see how you did.
You may also now see your
grade in the gradebook.
>> Some of our tests are proctored, and
we'll talk about the proctoring
services that we use a bit later.
We may also run surveys
through this interface.
Surveys are just like tests, but
they're ungraded and typically untimed,
although usually they'll only
be open for a certain window.
Generally, you should receive
announcements from your class when tests
and surveys are open, so you shouldn't
need to check this page very often.
Just come back whenever a survey or
a test is announced.